про прилюдно не нову глобальну
зовнішньополітичної стратегії євросоюзу
адже води річки magari не натер ховає
шакали втомимося годиною з телицем новий
документ по стрибні стратегія була у
хвала щодо 2000 витрачав уроку та вигляд про
справах shadow проливалася 1 rectum
на трейді і русі і в криму і на сході
україни в брюсселі ви вирішили світло джен
цієї євросоюз втомлюємося годиною стукнувся
основи його ви іклами
the moonlit видно інша концепт
стратегія 2016 зайнялася 64 ніг ступні
слову за верховну просто особі з ес
зовнішньою політикою то політика б спайкою
біля річки принаймні вона була зірки там
наші партнери відсікають євросоюзу що
when we give раватом його жив його роль
суті суеца і гаранту ваня глобальне
bespeco
ми зможемо ефективно дієта лише це гіг
що проти там йому спину
розум шляхом та поливаючи глобальна
стратегія за зовнішню пилу так це пилу
так і bespeco багатий експорт
отче микола ще у nuvi стратегія буде
прописано створа не армією з про плани і
ден обраних сил заявлялося чому на
нову руку protective не стала вся і в
сашу документі є просто виправити
кут осі оборони економічний і кібер
bespeco так вже про боротьбу з тероризмом
автор притиснувши від принципу європейська
політика оборони прописані щини зовсім
читання
проте створа не європейської армії нато
та європейського союзу та дайте проїхати до
датського регулярну армію через
підземні для Європи і ми вірно можна
місту proposal вони спектру тіснота до
також постала не США і Канада.
злісних змін впали вниз і стратегію 2003
уроку циpку зайти арешт щодо Москви
ящура нижчої раси а називалася
стратегічним партнером that appear
взаємними жеру салим то москвою
називаються ключовим стратегічним ви
ілом yes
проте формулювання про документ на
можна назвати ірис креми з на його
знання все криму росію і на рік і про
дестабілізуючою роль москвою на сході
україни у документі підфарбовуєте
продумує для суті ви сміливо венозних
мир і strf стану телицю в це до 3 травня
між
водного права на 1 годину є звучать і
marussia добував одні супер а що це
стеф брати я хочу інтереси брюссель це
Москви уникати mute